this is a production of Cornell
University so I'm not alone 3 I'm a grad
student at the University of New
Hampshire right now and I'm gonna
present some material that I did for my
masters at the University of Maryland
some stuff we're working on at UNH and
some of it has been funded by there and
I also wanted to do a little shameless
self-promotion while I have a captive
audience so if you want more information
on the stuff I'm talking about today you
can go to no-till vegies org and then I
also just released the first four
episodes of a podcast that was the
result of a ser partnership grant that I
thought and I would love it if you would
check it out tell everybody about it my
final report is due at the end of the
month
so check it out the first four episodes
are all about organic matter so it's
very appropriate ok but today I'm going
to talk about organic rotational no-till
for vegetables which is a little
different than the title that I
initially submitted so it's appropriate
that this is the North East cover crop
Council the first project I'm going to
talk about took place in Maryland
looking at forage radish and then going
into spring vegetables I worked with ray
while then the current project is in New
Hampshire and Maine mostly the day and
I'm going to percent is from Maine
actually from my family's farm we turned
it into a little experiment light and
that is with rich Smith at UNH so the
the big question how can we create the
optimal conditions for crop growth which
include soil moisture nutrient
availability weeds and temperature
everybody knows that while at the same
time conserving and improving soil
reducing erosion increasing soil organic
matter it's especially hard in vegetable
systems if there's one thing that's
coming across and all the vegetable
stalks it's that this is really hard
vegetable systems are really complex
everybody does it a little bit
differently so this is just kind of a
limps of some options that you can try
and then everybody has to put it all
together in their own unique way and so
to that last point how can we do it to
meet the different scales of vegetable
producers everybody has a different
favorite piece of equipment a different
budget they're working with so there's
nothing standardized about vegetable
production system and more and more
we're seeing small growers entering the
market and so while they may not cover a
large land base they're very important
population in terms of providing people
with a living providing fresh produce to
the market so can cover crops facilitate
Noto this is just a slide to show that
not only can cover crops do a lot of
different things everything that they do
is interconnected and so ultimately we
care about crop growth but to get to
crop growth we have to be thinking about
how does that affect nitrogen or how
does the cover crop affect nitrogen
availability soil water needs those
things that I mentioned and it's not you
know it's not necessarily linear
everything just connects everything else
so
the four R's of nutrient management I
think are very applicable to cover
cropping you have to pick the right
product the right time the right place
and the right rate so for spring crops
we're thinking about soil temperature we
want it to be warm enough everybody's
talked about that which means that we
can't have a lot of soil cover because
that's just gonna keep the soil cold we
want enough soil water but our problem
in spring tends to be too much water not
too little water I mean the climb is
variable so we do get these dry Springs
but in general historically in the
spring the problem is too much water you
can't get on the fields and we need
enough nitrogen early in spring that's
related to soil temperature and finally
in every cropping system we can't have
too many weeds
radish it's this very unique cover crop
it's you know become popular in the last
10-15 years folks and vegetable
production systems hate on the radish a
little bit because it is another
Brassica and so if you're growing a lot
of brassicas people are really hesitant
to introduce the radish cover crop but
if you can manage to fit it into your
rotation it has some amazing properties
so it's their project that I worked on
for my masters was using low low residue
winter killed cover crops we looked for
others that would do the same thing that
four-eyed reddish does and there just
isn't one out there it's unique
so after it winter kills it leaves if
you had a good stand and you got it in
early enough basically zero weeds it's
completely weed free it looks like
somebody threw a pair of quat they
didn't there are all these little radish
carcasses but other than that very low
residue the soil warms up nicely and you
can go in this is not a no-till planter
this is just a regular made Ermac
planter you can go in and direct seed
no-till into this
um if you don't have a mater Mac planter
you can go in and direct seed no-till
with an earth way you do occasionally
have to pick out the dried radish
carcass it doesn't work quite as well as
if you have a larger cedar but it can
work um so I mentioned soil moisture
that's important because you can't get
on the field when it's too wet so I was
interested in looking at all right well
how much does radish affect soil
moisture so we had an experiment we had
four radish oats a radish oat mixture
and the no cover and so this line here
is 80% of the plastic limit which is
sort of what you would consider alright
you can get on the field without
destroying your soil if you're you're
within below 80% of the plastic limit so
these are the rain events on the x-axis
and you can see that when with the oat
cover crop which is high residue and it
also winter kills there are very few
points in this span of time when you can
actually get on the field so I looked at
in terms of the workable days and with
oats there are very small windows with
radish it's as good as if you had no
cover crop basically and so when people
use the argument well I don't want to
plan a cover crop because I need the
soil to be dry in spring well you can
plant a radish and it will be just as
dry and in fact you'll probably get
better infiltration so you'll have
better subsoil moisture and if you
didn't have a cover crop there
so so temperature another thing we need
the temperature to be high enough so
that we'll get some mineralization going
on so that your seeds can germinate and
forage radish in red is almost the same
as no cover crop but you can see that
oats as you would expect higher residue
keeps the soil temperature down
um so how does that translate to
nitrogen availability so on the bottom
here we've got Julian day so just that's
basically March and cumulative degree
days and then on the top we've got soil
nitrate nitrogen for the top 20
centimeters and so what you see is that
with the radish and the radish and oat
you get a spike once you kind of hit
this critical level when that you get
increasing degree days you get a spike
in the available nitrogen so right when
your plants are going to start growing
and you need the nitrogen it's getting
mineralized from the radish that's not
happening with the oat it's also not
happening when you don't have a cover
crop they're getting a significant boost
in nitrogen early in the spring you want
to take advantage of that you don't want
to wait for it to leach out so it ends
up being about 40 to 50 pounds of
nitrogen per acre
so this is a no-till spinach crop right
after after radish just really quickly
yields we had foresight years total this
this Clarksville site up here was in the
Piedmont a really nice soil not to abuse
the Y soil is a coastal plain soil silt
loam and it's rather abused so the yield
that Clarksville tend to be a lot higher
and they were just as good in the
no-till as in the tilled plots which is
you know a lot of people would be
surprised by that but we did not see
that at why and I think it's because the
soil just isn't it was soil sort of at
the why I would say is kind of addicted
to tillage it's one of those soils that
can't produce a good crop without
tillage it just doesn't have the soil
structure needed to support a crop
one thing that people ask a lot when I
talk about radishes is what about the
holes when you're direct seeding don't
you lose a lot of seeds into the holes
and in fact Steve can come up in the
holes but what we found is that no-till
planting led to equal or better
emergence as planting after tillage so
with tillage you eliminate those holes
but you don't get as good germination
you don't get as good emergence so no
the holes don't seem to limit that but
like I said you need to have good enough
soil to support the crop growth not all
vegetable crops do well in this no-till
situation it seems that some take a
little longer to mature we did some
lettuce and kohlrabi and they were just
slower so they did mature a couple weeks
later but if you're eager to get that
crop out of the field then it might not
be as good an option I did some carrots
in Maine's no-till carrots after radish
and I found that they did very well the
the yields were not quite as good but I
think that was just because we actually
in this case got lower emergence and had
reduced dance but so just to summarize
this system relies on seeding your cover
crop around mid to late August your
cover crop grows in fall your cover crop
dies over the winter pretty much the
whole Northeast region your cover crop
or forage radish will die then you grow
a cash crop makes money then you grow
another crop or another cover crop
all right so that's kind of the spring
the spring early system where you're
looking for low residue more soil
warming you want to get rid of the water
the excess water so you don't want your
fields to be too wet so for summer crops
though again you definitely don't want
weeds but it's actually not as important
for the for the soil temperature well I
shouldn't say that it is important for
the soil temperature to be high but you
want the soil cover because you want it
to retain the moisture when you're
getting into the summer and you really
need that mulch
so but high residue systems like the
roller crimper that's discussed a lot in
grain systems and discussed a lot in
Pennsylvania and Maryland in those
places it was really interesting I don't
know if you folks went to Stephens talk
today but it was interesting to see that
you just can't get the kind of biomass
in northern climates that they talked
about in Pennsylvania and Maryland we
can't do it no matter how hard we try
and so to get adequate weed suppression
in those high residue systems you really
need almost four tons of dry matter and
if you look at the data like I love
looking at other people's presentations
and I'm like nope nope nope like almost
nobody gets out amount of dry matter in
their cover crops and so a much more
realistic number for us in the Northeast
is about half of that for a pretty good
cover crop performance
they can also be hard to terminate
especially if you're drawing rye with
vetch or something and you get a
synchrony between when those crops
mature and you have to wait until a
certain point so really these high
residue systems sound great but we need
a lot more flexibility if people are
going to adopt them we need to be able
to terminate the cover crops more easily
and we need some kind of supplemental
weed control because we just aren't
going to get the biomass that they can
get in Maryland so what about tarps
tarps have been promoted in the market
gardener a lot of small farmers are
using them in the context of permanent
raised beds but as far as we knew there
weren't a whole lot of people who were
combining actually we don't know of
really anybody who is combining high
residue cover crops and tarps
there were these folks in Canada
unfortunately I couldn't I don't speak
French so I couldn't I think they may
have had something about their
experiment but I couldn't understand it
but I did find this picture online of
what they did so what we did though we
had an initial preliminary trial two
years ago and we tried black and clear
tarps and what we learned was clear
doesn't really work in our climate so we
went to black so then that we modified
it and so this past season what we did
was we seeded Brian Betz end of
September again that's not a date when
you're gonna get very high biomass but
it's a really realistic date for farmers
in the Northeast the mid August even
though I would advocate that for forage
radish is not very realistic and the
September is so the the biomass that we
got in these two fields and my farm was
about 4,000 killed between 3500 and 4500
killing ant kilograms per hectare so
around two tons that's what it looked
like so the treatments we applied on
June 5th were rolled with a disengage
rotor tiller and parked that's what that
looked like and the reason we that is
because we also do not have a roller
crimper we mowed with a sickle bar mower
and tarped we had to borrow that and
then we motive sickle bar mower and we
didn't tarp and then finally we tilled
in tarped and we tilled and didn't tarp
so this is what it looked like when we
mowed with the sickle bar mower it was
really hard because it was a push one
piece yes and it was hard to get the
residue to lay flat it kind of shook off
to the side so I did the best I could
but it was a little messy
then we tarp is just four mill UV
stabilized black plastic held down with
sod staples so this is what the the
three different sort of residue
management looked like this tailed
treatment not I know that most farmers
would never do that
like that's messy so that's not
your ideal tailed treatment but your
ideal tailed treatment you would have
killed your covered hawk way earlier and
incorporated it so it's hard to deal
with high biomass cover crops if you're
working in a tilled system this is what
the mode one looked like and then rolled
looked like that so we had two fields
kind of next to each other but a little
different soil types left the tarps on
for four weeks basically the whole month
of June then on July 5th we transplanted
the cabbages they were bigger than that
and to do that again we don't have any
fancy no-till transplanting equipment so
what we did was actually use a tree
seedling dubler you stand up and you
make a hole
it sounds really laborious but when you
have undergrads it doesn't take too long
no I actually don't think it took that
long but if we do this again we will you
know measure how long it takes so we can
do an enterprise budget of sorts so this
is what it ended up looking like so this
is a mode and tarped this is a tilled
and not tarped and then we did have sub
plots of weeded and not weeded and so
here in the mode in tarp you can't see a
huge difference between the weeded and
not we did here with the tilled and not
tarped there's a pretty substantial
difference between the weeded and not we
did so it's not like these these fields
were weed free or anything there was a
substantial weed seed bank a substantial
weed problem this is a Roldan tarped
again that middle flag there is marking
weeded and unweeded you can't really see
a difference mode and not harped which
is one of those treatments that no
farmer in her right mind would ever do
but we're researchers that's what this
looked like so the that's the not weeded
part this is the weeded part we
ended up harvesting a little bit early
these were these are small cabbages
they're tiara cabbage from johnny's
they're intended to be a two to three
pound head kind of a high-density
planting but we had a severe porcupine
infestation which we kept that bay with
a 22 but we were like we gotta get our
data out of the field so they were there
really beautiful cabbages if I do say so
myself
and our yields so
these three are the tarped treatments
Reds weeded blue is not weeded not a
huge difference between weeded and not
we did where we had a tarp
those are our tailed treatments where we
didn't have a tarp and we tailed an
enormous difference between we did and
not we did so if you're not using a tarp
you really have to control your weeds
which is what you know most farmers do
you control your weeds and again mow no
tarp just kind of joke
uh weed biomass so as a reminder the
average cover crop biomass was 35 to
4,500 kilograms per hectare so where
there was no tarp substantially more
weed biomass this is just for the
unweeded plots by the way both field
pretty similar story where there was
lower biomass there was a little bit
more of a we more weeds even in the tarp
block in the tarp plots
it was mostly pigweed and purslane and
research has shown that tarping or
solarization does not really affect
pigweed and personally they have a very
very high temperature tolerance but
there still weren't a ton of weeds so I
haven't looked at the moisture and
temperature data I do have some of it
but we hypothesized that warmer
temperatures during carping increased
nitrogen mineralization so you're
solving some of that problem of cool
soils in spring by having a tarp on
there for a little while and getting
everything going and Katy just showed me
a graph from a on-farm experiment that
out one of her collaborating farmers was
working on who actually had a very
similar experiment and there was a
substantial like three degree difference
3 to 5 degree difference under the tarp
which is what you would expect so we all
also hypothesize that more water
available in the no-tell thoughts is
good for the crops there's less stress
during dry period so to summarize this
rotation looks like alright we plant our
cover crops they grow a little bit in
the fall not a lot they mostly grow in
the spring we tarp them for around the
month of June we know for weeks works
we'd love to do some more experiments to
see whether we can get away with shorter
tarp duration
this project was pretty much unfunded
but we're we just put in an application
and hopefully we'll get funding and we
can answer some more of these questions
then you grow your cash crop and then
move into whatever's necked next so
that's just kind of a proof of concept
but what I like about this system even
though I hate plastic and I hate being
like yeah plastic it provides so much
flexibility because it kills the cover
crop which is often a problem it
suppresses weed and it warms the soil so
it's like solving so many of the
problems that we have and needs reduce
tiller systems and so but it doesn't
just have to be Ryan vetch it could be
for instance a winter killed oat cover
crop and then you could put the tarp on
earlier and get stuff going I really
don't know but I think there's like many
possibilities for applying the system to
other other time periods you do want it
to be during a period when there's some
heat so you're going to get that warming
under the tarp but how am i doing on
time okay so the way forward I think I
said in the description I was gonna like
talk about how to integrate all these
systems which sounded like a really good
idea but then when I was putting this
together last night I was like I don't
know how to do it I don't know other way
for it is but I think I think that when
we have multiple systems where we can
eliminate tillage events farmers will
get creative and string those multiple
systems together so that we can
eliminate multiple tillage events so but
the problem with this whole system is
that cover crops do take time to grow
there's no way around it and so what is
the opportunity cost using this tarping
system also takes a significant amount
of time so what's the opportunity cost
of a four week tarping period in May or
June so that's why we really do want to
drill down on how long do you have to
put that tarp on if it's the beginning
of June can you leave it on for a week
and get close to the same effects or do
you really have to have it for four
weeks
it's hard to look at anything that has
to do with timing it's really hard
because there are so many confounding
factors was it how how moist the soil
was when you put it on was it this was
it that so we've tried to design an
experiment for the future where we can
really get at some of those questions
but we'll see if we get money so the
great thing was we salvaged some of
enough of the cabbage from the
porcupines for our data that we also
donated about 3000 pounds of cabbage
bag so that was awesome felt good yeah
so that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the weed communities were definitely
different the weed communities in the
tarps were really not diverse it was
really like pigweed purslane so the tarp
selected for resistant weeds but I
didn't measure the weed density
I only measured the weed biomass so I
can't definitively say but I think from
having looked at it that there was lower
density in the tarp plots but I didn't
measure that
you
yeah yeah so I didn't mention that but
that is a really important part of this
system so for that weed seed destruction
you need enough moisture so ideally
you'd put on the tarps when the after
rain when your soils are at field
capacity or if it is dry you could
irrigate even if they're above Field
capacity they'll drain so go ahead and
put the tarps on when it's wet but yeah
if you put the tarps on when it's dry
there's also no moisture going into that
system so when you go to transplant your
crops there's not going to be much
moisture but if you put the tarp on I
feel capacity your soil will still be a
filled capacity when you transplant
those crops they were basically
guaranteeing that you've got good
moisture when you're transplanting your
crops
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu